[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me at Winston Marshall at The
Spectator buildings in London today I'm
joined by American conservative activist
commentator and writer and host of a
show on The Daily wire as of last year
Candace thank you so much for joining me
I'm actually very pleased to be here
yeah um uh it's uh it's a it's a great
pleasure I've read your book during my
lockdown experience and um and you've
been very busy it's been a very busy
couple of years for you it has I feel
like I have not stopped moving between
having two children and getting married
and then all the projects that I've been
working on yeah it has been a
tremendously busy couple of years
um well
I want to kind of get straight into it
uh you earlier in October were
photographed with Kanye West so on this
show I've been exploring free speech in
the creative Industries it's it's one of
the main themes here and uh you're
photographed with Kanye your friend I
believe I'm not sure or yay as he is now
referred to with the shirts White lives
matter what's the story
you know the story really is that yay
messaged me we are friends and he told
me that he needed me to be at Paris
fashion week and he was a bit nebulous
on the details he just sort of said I
really really really need you there and
I wasn't sure if he wanted me there as a
spectator if he wanted me there to be a
part of the show but I knew that I
wanted to support him and the reason for
that is I believe that he is a creative
genius and actually a big piece of my
story and what gave me the courage to
speak out about who I am as an
individual uh was Kanye's music growing
up as a girl who had nothing Kanye's
music really is almost 10 years into the
future in terms of calling out the media
and way that they kind of created an
enemy out of him as he was getting
started and so I was like absolutely
jumped on to a plane to Paris basically
in 24 with 24 hours notice not even 24
hours notice I think it was more like
six hours notice in order for me to get
there on time I got there to his show
and he had two shirts one was black and
one was white and he said I really need
you to wear this and he held it up and
it said White lives matter and I
instantly understood the meaning behind
it I understood what he was trying to do
I understood the creative genius behind
it and it it was very crucial to make
such an obvious statement right it
really was just an obvious statement
obviously White lives matter
but it really offered a commentary on
the black lives matter movement and the
lies that we have been told about black
lives matter as being this message of
unity we're not saying that white lives
don't matter but and in reality what the
black lives matter movement organization
did was further divide people racially
and also silence people you virtually
especially in the states were not
allowed to speak if you were white you
were convicted on the basis of your skin
color this wasn't about fighting racism
this was about creating racism and so
white people were being told at the same
time that they needed to shut up but
also that they had to keep speaking out
Against Racism or else guilty it was
almost a witch trial in many ways so
wait so just to understand that does
that mean that the white life so you say
that's very clear but I still don't
fully understand is that was it a
provocative shirt yes to highlight the
problems with black lives matter or was
he actually sang and were you saying
it's more specifically the White lives
matter like is that something it was
challenging the hypocrisy right so if it
was true that you know black lives
matter and we're not seeing White lives
matter and putting on a white lives
matter t-shirt wouldn't matter it didn't
certainly didn't matter when in the
states there was this small movement
that took place after black lives matter
called the Asian lives matter movement
you were allowed to put a t-shirt on
that said Spanish lives matter you could
have said Asian lives matter you could
have said Italian lives matter but this
statement White lives matter which
obviously they do created a firestorm
right and white lives matter in America
has been called a
um a hate speech or something it's just
the term itself is supposed is allegedly
they say it's uh in science it's a
racist white supremacist Mantra or
something without any proof of that
metal right there's no for that there's
no historical connotation it wasn't like
you had klansmen walking around wearing
white lives Matter t-shirts they just
said this is something you're not
allowed to say and before you even say
it we're going to condemn it as a racist
phrase well if White lives matter is a
racist phrase in a symbol of white
nationalism then black lives matter is a
racist phrase and a symbol of black
nationalism it's either both of these
phrases are wrong or both of these
phrases are fine and it we basically
were in my opinion patronized by the
White Community with the black square
and Kanye or you black Americans full
stop patronized by people constantly
having white people wearing black lives
Matter t-shirts and putting up black
lives matter signs and your life matters
I want you to know that your life
matters I get that thank you I'm not a
victim I don't need you to tell me that
my life matters I need to live my life
according to how I how I view myself as
an individual not according to my skin
color and yet for two black people to
put on a white lives matter shirt
people found that to be problematic
that's hypocritical is the is was the
movement though I mean it seems like a
semantic problem so black lives matter a
lot of the energy behind it was a deep
uh unease with anti-black racism which
I'm sure you would agree to be anti-anti
racism uh uh but mixed up with a slogan
that's quite provocative perhaps by
intent perhaps that's why it was so
successful in in capturing the
imagination of so many so a lot of the
energy behind black lives matter not the
organization not the language but there
was a genuine concern with anti-black
racism in America I don't believe I
believe there was a genuine concern but
that concern was created by the media
telling you to be genuinely concerned
right not because of facts not because
people were looking at actual data and
facts and determining that hey look it
actually does look like black lives are
suffering in America and that there's an
instance of police brutality
disproportionate police brutality
towards black Americans the facts
portray that narrative right the facts
are that white men are killed more often
by police officers and unarmed shooting
the facts are that black Americans over
represent in terms of violence in the
states right so you have about six to
seven percent of the population being
black men that account for over 40
percent of all the homicides right so
this whole concept that if black lives
actually mattered you would talk about
the issue which is black on black crime
not police brutality it's a made-up
narrative to Foster this resentment and
this anger in society and talking about
that and saying okay if you really
believe black lives matter let's talk
about black on black crime was forbidden
we can't talk about black on black crime
we have to pretend that we're suffering
because of an institution of racism that
does not exist the feeling and the
sentiment behind it was legitimate but
it was curated by the media right and so
people felt they watched the George
Floyd uh uh incident and they felt the
media told them this is what happened
the media lied about that incident as
well they lied about who George Floyd
was and they created this false idol in
terms of George Floyd and then ever
everybody else just got on board not
because they were horrible people but
because they were absent the facts well
you you say this but your organization
brexit a non-profit organization uh it
just is self-described as being to
encourage minority groups and
communities uh to for advancement I'd
say so so implicit there is that some
groups are behind or some groups need
help and and is that is that a correct
interpretation yes but it's not because
of this concept of institutional racism
it's because of the decisions that we're
making so we what we encourage is for
Black Americans to stop falling for this
liberal narrative to stop falling from
this idea that you're a victim in this
Society because of the color of your
skin and to instead see yourself as an
individual to embrace free market
capitalism which we believe in uh that
you and that your individuals your
individual decisions will determine your
successes that's what I believe to my
core black Americans because of this
sort of cultural training that happens
for and foremost in the education system
we're taught we are literally taught
from a time that we get into school that
we're victims right that's a plague upon
the black mind to plague upon any mind
if you just say to someone you're never
going to be able to get ahead you're
actually forming an attitude and
perspective that makes it impossible to
get ahead right I see everything as a
slight right as a black American I walk
outside and someone cuts me off and and
as any other individual you go it's
normally what happens people are not
great all the time it's black American I
go
it's because I'm black because I can't
get ahead why do I even go outside right
and instead we're saying no you're not a
victim we're or we are all victims right
we are victims of our own decision
making I'm a big believer that when you
believe in your own when you commit to
this idea that you are a victim you very
much become your own oppressor Black
America is oppressing itself because we
have bought into this vicious narrative
that we're nothing but victims but
that's the Paradox of a victimha culture
is that even if you are a victim if you
take on the mentality of a victim it
will make your situation worse right but
would you can see any ground that that
blacks in America are have experienced
setbacks because of the way Society is
structured I would concede that we are
definitely experiencing setbacks in the
education system because of the
commitment to things like critical race
Theory and because we are quite
literally being poisoned brainwash is
real black Americans are being
systematically brainwashed against their
own future teachers and it is being
helped by an ecosystem that is furthered
by cultural icons and people in
Hollywood that patronize us and keep
telling us look this is because you're
black stop telling black Americans that
they can't do well in this society and
you will start to see that they do well
because they're on equal fitting footing
and I think the like I said if you look
into the data in the statistics it
supports my narrative because it's a
true narrative black Americans in the
1950s okay where there was true
institutionalized racism my grandfather
grew up you were living in a segregated
Society my grandfather could not go into
white places quite literally despite
that the black Americans in 1950s under
Jim Crow were outpacing white Americans
in terms of economic growth right and
every statistic black Americans are
doing worse right so you would never
make the argument if you were saying
individual that America has become a
more racist country since the era of Jim
Crow so then you have to think
critically and say what changed what
changed was culture changed black
Americans families used to be together
when you start to look and examine
statistics between white Americans and
black Americans you will notice some
disparities right but disparity is not
discrimination disparities can happen
because of the decisions that are being
made we are not coming from two parent
households anymore and the implications
of what happens when you come from a
broken household are severe actually if
you examine the statistics between black
American families that are together with
a mother and a father and black and
white American families there's
virtually no disparity and these are the
tougher conversations that people don't
want to have because that it implicates
that our culture is sick black American
culture is sick and actually American
culture altogether is becoming sicker
every single day do you think that this
narrative is is gaining traction are you
are you finding that people are agreeing
with your narrative and getting behind
you on this yeah I do when I first got
started it was more than an uphill
client him it was it was extreme people
had never seen a black American that not
just wasn't conservative but that had
the audacity to be conservative right
I'm not the first black American
conservative I'm definitely not the
brightest one I mean I would tell you
Condoleezza Rice is way more
accomplished than me I think Thomas soul
is one of the most brilliant people that
I've ever read and I will say the same
about Clarence Thomas you know Supreme
Court Justice way more brilliant than me
and way more well-read than me but these
individuals when they were smeared and
libeld and told that they hated
themselves and were called Uncle Toms
and Coons they didn't rise to the fight
in the way that I have and so I think
that that is different people oh my God
we've just called you and Uncle Tom how
dare you keep saying that and I'm sort
of like no the gloves are off let's do
this and I come from a place of anger
that transformed into action so I went
through this cycle of anger when I woke
up civilized I used to be a liberal and
believe in my own victimhood and when I
really began to understand what was
happening because I started reading
Thomas Soul
um I grew very angry and I wanted to
fight so that all black Americans could
understand what I have come to
understand and I realized that that
flight that that fight has to take place
on the cultural Battlefield right you
got to go after the Hollywood types
because that's where black Americans are
learning unfortunately because we come
from these broken down households we're
turning to culture to dictate how we
think is that you describe you know
terms such as Uncle Tom and other racist
terms that you're getting from let's say
liberal America is that not a sign that
America is quite racist it is well there
I mean the racism that I experienced
typically which people like I said you
can racism exists I've never denied that
racism does exist in fact my argument is
that racism will forever exist right the
question is not whether or not racism
exists there's always going to be
someone who hates somebody right maybe
you're Chinese you hate the Japanese
people maybe you're Indian and you hate
uh Mexicans right that's never going to
change the quest question is whether or
not racism is preventing an individual
if whether it's institutionalized
whether it's preventing me from being
able to do something because of the
color of my skin and yet it is helping
somebody because of the color of their
skin that does not exist in America okay
so you have made a film The Greatest lie
ever told which I think ties a lot of
these things together but I haven't seen
the film can you tell me about it yeah
so I had to sort of in order to get
black Americans to really understand the
deception of the lies I had to unpack
one of the biggest lies of the last few
years which was the George Floyd story
and the rise of BLM and the rise of BLM
being it's now transformed into a 90
million dollar organization and
everyone's putting up the bumper
stickers and they say oh well that's
just the movements different from the
organization no it's not of course when
people are feeling guilty and they want
to donate and they see all these signs
they donate to Black lives matter the
organization that's why it has this war
chest of 90 million dollars and it
started with making people realize and
and this is the purpose of the film that
media is your enemy the media is
deciding for you every single day who is
the villain and who is the hero right
and you're buying that narrative
believing that the media has your best
interest at heart and what the media
always has at its heart is more power
that they can Garner from themselves
maybe it's power to elect politicians
right and so I had to show people the
other side of the George Floyd story
when the George floor Floyd event
happened the millionaire was open and
shut it was a racist cop it almost it
was like a cartoon a racist cop is
patrolling the streets sees a black man
and just starts standing on his neck
wanting him to die and this is what's
happening because police are racist
nobody ever talked about who George
Floyd was nobody talked about the fact
that fentanyl pills were found in the
police cruiser nobody talked about the
fact that George Floyd asked to be put
on the ground that George Floyd was
sitting in a police vehicle with his
drug dealer the reason that Derek
shoving was called as backup was because
he resisted arrest for eight minutes
right and they kept saying hey man
please calm down what did you did you
take some drugs nobody talked about the
fact what he said I ate too many drugs
right it every indication from his
autopsy report indicates that he had an
overdose right the the lethal the lethal
that that video who was not moved by
that video of him I don't I don't deny
people being moved by videos I actually
very much but the the police officer it
was clear that he shouldn't have had his
his was it neon on his neck so that's a
lie that might that might that's why you
should watch documentary that it debunks
people didn't even watch the trial they
just watched the media narrative the
police officer the the black uh police
head
testified that from the angle that we
all saw it which was somebody that was
on the street named darnella Frazier
recording it it very much looks like the
police offer is police officers on
George Floyd's neck but then which the
media never showed you the other angle
which is from the police officers
cameras that are on their body cameras
he then testifies what about from this
angle and it shows you that the knee is
actually his knee is actually here right
under his neck on his back which is what
they learn in the police academy that
they're supposed to do when they put a
suspect on the ground right now if you
want to have an honest debate about
whether or not once you realize that
this man is very clearly having an
overdose now when I say having an
overdose
the average person it takes just three
milliliters of fentanyl for them have an
overdose George Floyd had 11 milliliters
okay it's like it's it's just forget it
at the tip I had a forensic pathologist
and they're describing he doesn't have a
hoarseness race he's he's amazed that
people are not talking about the fact
that he was in the car with his drug
dealer clearly he had drugs right
clearly he was trying to get rid of the
drugs they found chewed up pills in the
back of the police cruiser they tried to
arrest him peacefully for minutes and
minutes he starts saying put me on the
ground he says I can't breathe before he
even gets on the ground he demands to be
put on the ground right now if you want
to have a debate about whether or not
the police should have discerns that he
was having an overdose and maybe they
should have let him lay on his back and
breathe I'm happy to have that debate I
would say that absolutely and that it
would be a totally sensible debate to
have right so it says like listen I
don't care how you're supposed to hold
this person
you realize that this person is saying
he can't breathe you're realizing that
he maybe did ingest some drugs what is
the right thing to do right the wrong
thing to do is put your knee on the back
of his how are they to know that he
ingested the drugs they have a guy and
this is like we've become a society that
is so critical police officers not
realizing what happens in a second right
you get a call there's a guy sitting in
a crew you don't know but he's with his
drug dealer you don't know what he's
doing if you watch the full tape not the
nine minutes but the full tape they're
going hey man what are you doing why are
you acting so erotic what's going on man
he's like no no I don't want to go into
the police car I'm claustrophobic I'm
claustrophobic put me on the ground
right put me on the ground and he's
saying he's claustrophobic but they
arrived on the scene and he was sitting
in his car by the way which my
documentary also shows he was previously
arrested just a couple of months before
and the same exact circumstance happened
drugs were found in his vehicle he's
trying to get rid of them last second I
mean this is a story and I told it with
tremendous compassion to George Floyd
because I believe that he was a drug
addict I sat down with his roommates I
spoke to him and drug addiction is hard
I don't know any person who doesn't have
a family member that is going through
drug addiction right that we are facing
a drug crisis all across the world this
should have been a story that brought
people together the idea that Derek
shovin arrived there and did this
because he was a black man is completely
outrageous he never called him in the
n-word or should anything that was
racist to him right I guess what's so
shocking to a British viewers is that
even in this country
even regardless of race is holding
someone down like that it doesn't it
doesn't happen they're literally trained
to do it so if you wanted to get again
totally different debate of whether or
not they should be able to do this but
keep in mind George Floyd is six seven
okay he's huge I mean his roommate's
describing how huge he is you have
somebody that is six seven and pretend
you're a police officer right who's got
a who has a violent record not just like
a record a violent record George Floyd a
tourist who went to prison for five
years he went to prison more than that
but the big one that he had recently
been released in prison for was for
putting a gun to a woman's breaking into
our house pretending to be the water
department searching ransacking her home
for drugs and putting a gun to her
abdomen you know while her child watched
this is a violent criminal so it's so
easy for us to sit here and say well you
know we just think that here in the UK
police officers should be nice you don't
it is your it is life or death every
single time you are a police officer
right well there's a lot of the notable
difference is that there's guns in your
country and there isn't guns really over
here in this country was so the police
there's a lot more pressure on police to
do in those situations yeah well anyway
so you're thinking maybe are you saying
that George Floyd could have had a gun
well no but I'm saying that the training
of police will be very different in your
country than it would be it might well
full stop there has to he there wasn't a
gun used on George Floyd so that's not
even a part of this debate there was no
gun used on him he wasn't BT but there
was no gun use on him at all they just
were trying to arrest him someone with a
tremendously violent record right a drug
addict who was six seven right to even
be able if George Floyd wanted to fight
them he could have overcome them that's
the truth he's six seven and he is in
fact a violent criminal now that doesn't
it's it's sad that he died there's no
question to me no matter what when
somebody dies it's very sad but we need
to tether ourselves to having a
realistic discussion if you want to
debate whether or not police should ever
have a right to put their knee on the
top of someone's back right we can have
that debate but what we should not be
doing is pretending that this was about
race what we should not be doing is not
acknowledging the fact that George Floyd
would have made it to the police
um officers their compounds completely
safely had he complied right he asked to
be taken out of the car when they were
trying to peaceably arrest him he was
acting erratic they didn't know that he
had consumed drugs they have no way to
determine that and so you know hindsight
is 2020 would have could have should
have now with all of the knowledge and
the facts that we know now but the
majority of people still don't know all
the facts and that was the purpose of my
documentary let's have a real honest
conversation about this story which
shocked the world absent very little
facts about who this person was and how
they got there um does the film go is it
specifically about Floyd or does it go
into the BLM organization as well both
so I wanted I wanted to tell George
Floyd's story because after meeting his
roommates I felt tremendous compassion
for him and for his struggles as a drug
addict and then I wanted to tell Derek
Chauvin story because after realizing
that the media just told you he was a
racist not a sliver of facts behind that
and this man is now spending 23 hours a
day in a top security prison how does
anybody feel okay about that it boggles
my mind there are two victims in my mind
in the story and then I wanted to move
on to talk about that this narrative
which we were all lied to about inflated
an organization that purported to be
about black lives mattering
I went into the finances yeah what did
you find what I found was that millions
and millions of dollars are going to
trans organizations
what kind of organizations quite
literally trans organizations like we
focus on providing trans houses one was
we are focused on building the first
ever fully transgender District in San
Francisco we are focused on they're all
buying houses in building districts I'll
say that it's a lot of real estate we
are focused on providing a Oasis for
transgendered people in Ohio right house
of Gigi House of tulip
um a transgender District we are focused
on sex workers uh all sex workers how
does any of this go to furthering black
lives right we found that 30 plus
million dollars went to the stock market
I thought this was about tearing down
the institutions of white supremacy and
so it was important then to show people
that your emotions were guided you
donated to this organization and let's
see how black lives have been how have
been helped let's actually go back to
where this all started in Minneapolis
the crime rates up over 60 percent it's
a it's a completely destitute town the
people are going what just happened no
money has been given nobody even paid
George Floyd's rent the back rent that
happened because he died and his car is
running in the driveway his family
members who were given millions of
dollars didn't even go to collect his
belongings his roommates told me they
had no relationship with George Floyd
they had never met he had lived with him
for four to five years and they had
never met a single brother cousin
daughter friend nothing he was a drug
addict that was moved to Minnesota after
he came out of prison and we were so
supposed to believe that we needed to
feel bad for his family members didn't
even have the inkling to go collect his
belongings there were a lot of questions
here can I ask about the the BLM I'm
curious here because the BLM was the
organization and as in America over here
in Britain got huge support in in that
time in the music industry where I was
working if you didn't post a black
Square on your social media they came
after you in fact the band Hanson who
you might remember the song
who didn't exist because they didn't
exist they didn't post anything on their
social media their fans came after them
for not putting a black square and so
then had to issue an apology even though
they did not exist for not putting up a
black square and then BLM became the de
facto charity to donate to and so
where did that money go you've described
some of it am I right in Remembering as
90 million dollars the majority of it
going to trans organizations
um going to transgender organizations
the majority of going to the stock
market transgender organizations million
dollar homes bought for the owners who
uh Patrice colors is one of the founders
of black lives matter she married a
trans person
um that person then received eight
million dollars to her charity in Canada
purchased more real estate it's like a
real estate Empire almost
um nothing and he's holding these people
to account me yeah and the truth is that
everybody was duped and lied to and so I
do want to have compassion for
individuals who gave to this and I want
to have compassion for people who
stepped into this psychosis there are
very there are a lot of media driven
psychosis because psychosis full stop
right covid was a media driven psychosis
all right just after the Alum came
coveted or in between at the same time
and I have compassion for individuals
because when you your instincts are to
you want to help right I want I feel
Justice
yeah because it's propaganda right it is
is for some reason people are able to
understand propaganda when you examine
Germany in the 1930s if you're reading
about it different time oh we'll never
let that it's happening to the West
right now right the media is furthering
divide they are furthering these various
psychosis and people are becoming
you know and I hate to use the term Nazi
like because people it's so overused but
they are becoming like the brown shirts
posted black Square we're going to kill
you you know what I mean is the
sentiment poster black Square are your
best they're showing up and they're
stripping away people's entire
livelihoods because the media has driven
them into a psychosis and they have no
facts they have no data all they have is
emotion and the reason why they have no
facts and no data is because they're not
even being trained to think critically a
part of the ecosystem is an education
system which is now training people like
what I said earlier to just react
emotionally right to just believe you're
a victim because you're black right to
and then now to go attack someone
because they didn't post a black Square
this is psychotic this is quite
literally psychotic and it's difficult
for me to try to tow the line between
feeling compassion for their psychosis
and then being angry about their
psychosis how dare you ruin someone's
life in livelihood because you're an
idiot right because you're a prop you
know you're propagandized idiot I mean
to extent so I was certainly affected by
the video of Floyd I would say murder
but you probably would dispute that but
when it came to BLM they were so
explicitly anti-family anti-capitalist
anti the nuclear family to be more
specific and they were in a Marxist
organization that I was like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa how do how are we going
straight to this are there other
organizations that you think are worthy
of support every media driven psychosis
just to be clear is all about destroying
the family I mean covet what was that if
you see your grandmother you're a killer
if you want to hang out with your
friends and family you're a killer it's
it's creating this this loneliness right
of this individual feeling like it's not
good to Aspire to family the entire
LBGTQ million letters being tapped onto
it every day is anti-family right you
know and what happens when a child takes
a drug like Lupron which is used to to
sexually castrate pedophiles right is
that they become sexually castrated
right these people go on and they cannot
have productive sexual relationship
productive relationships a bunch of
formerly trans people are speaking out
about that what this drug has done to
their body they're not going to go on to
have productive families right they're
not going to be able to go on and have
productive families because they're
ruining their parts before they even
become adults right so it's actually and
this is very important it is the common
theme in all of the left's extreme
positions even the green New Deal
climate change Lobby which people go I
like the environment of course I like
the environment I want the environment
to stay healthy what you are seeing with
this Greta thundberg push it's not about
people that are just want the
environment to be healthy what you're
seeing when people are throwing you know
tomato soup on a van Gogh painting it's
a watermelon it's green on the outside
it's communist on the inside right and
you can see this when you start to
realize at the same time they are
encouraging kids in the classroom in the
United States at the very least I don't
know about here the politicians that
support the green New Deal like AOC
overseas
um and you know the language of people
like WETA thundberg and people like
Harry and Megan who recently received an
award for their uh commitment to climate
change is that they are receiving an
award because they're committing to not
having big families they got they
literally Prince Harry and Megan
receives an award for agreeing to only
have two children the kids in our
classrooms the United States are being
told that it would be bad for the planet
it is a wrong thing the future is
already ruined how selfish of you to
have a family that anti-family messaging
is that ant that marks this belief is
what they're hiding that's what's at the
root of everything that you're seeing do
you think that anti-natalist anti-family
is conscious or subconscious do they do
you think they really know they're doing
or do you think they've been marinated
in a philosophy and they don't really
understand what they're that's how
propaganda works and they never
understand it they don't I do not
believe that people that donated to
Black lives matter wanted to donate to
trans organizations I don't believe that
no they were impacted emotionally I
don't believe that the kids that are
skipping school and saying the planet's
going to be over in 10 years are doing
that and and agreeing I'm not going to
have kids because it's irresponsible are
doing that because they're anti-family
they're not connecting the dots it's
it's very important that people have the
courage to connect the dots it's what I
do full-time because where we land upon
is going to be the determination for my
children I've now got kids right I've
got I've got some real skin in this game
in this game and you have a bunch of
adults that are too scared to speak up
because despite the fact that I do
believe they represent a radical
minority they do own the airwaves right
they are a majority when you're talking
about the Hollywood types and they are
dominant in the sphere of influence and
so it's incumbent upon the majority my
belief is that we are the majority to
stop being silent and to have the
courage to say things
so how do we what do we say to encourage
people to have children people to have
families what how do we do that you say
it just like that we're doing it right
now right Having the courage to talk
about where that money went which people
now are too shy to admit they were wrong
because they become so radicalized by
the media and so angry and so committed
that it's quite embarrassing right it's
quite embarrassing to say oh well uh
turns out you know black lives matter
was a scam organization and in fact you
see they start to slowly backpedal and
they say oh well I never cared about the
organization it was about the movement
that's cowardice okay that is cowardice
the movement was the marketing firm for
the organization admit you were wrong
take down your signs if you want to
actually help black Americans stop
looking at us like we're children okay
tell us that we have to be just like
every other person in society which is
that how you behave and how you perform
will dictate your futures okay if you
commit to a life of crime if you if you
believe that these black kids that you
see looting and rioting targets right
are doing this in the name of racism and
not because they're going getting free
flat screen TVs you are furthering the
problem
is crime doesn't matter who commits it
kind of can I go back to Kanye West
because we've flowed on so I I went with
it but I I want to ask about uh Carney
or yay because
um after the White lives matter shirts
that you were photographed with in Paris
uh he's since then been banned across
social media for a series of what I
would call anti-semitic tweets
um if I may read one
um this is one tweet that had got him
suspended from Twitter which is I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people the
funny thing is I actually can't be
anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jew also you guys have toyed
with me and tried to blackball anyone
whoever opposes your agenda and
um he has then he said that of Adidas
again in October I can say anti-semitic
things and Adidas can't drop me but
Adidas have now gone and dropped him
which is worth four to eight percent of
Adidas's uh business but it's actually
worth one and a half billion dollars to
yeah so this is a major thing JP Morgan
although they claim this was before the
anti-symmetics stuff have dropped and
stopped doing business with him uh
Balenciaga have uh stopped doing
business from the production company
called MRC have shelved a documentary
about him creative artist agencies have
gone uh have dropped him Gap have closed
the Yeezy online store and you have on
your podcast carefully saying that you
weren't defending him but didn't sound
like a criticism saying that uh that
he's not anti-semitic that
um the the Tweet inspired questions
um and so I wanted to ask him on that
how is that sentence I'm a bit sleepy
tonight but when I wake up I'm going
Defcon 3 on Jewish people how is that
not anti-semitic I'm glad that you asked
that question and I think that it's
important to impress upon people the
timeline of when I responded to uh what
he tweeted I responded to what he
tweeted people now are like well you he
said this after blah blah when I did my
podcast I was responding to specifically
that tweet and what I said in which I
stand by is that the Tweet is incoherent
I don't know what death Con 3 means
right I know what deaf Con 3 is is he
which is a defense military strategy I
don't know what he's saying we should
ask him people were asking me to say
what he meant by this and you know I am
in a situation where I know Kanye
personally and I know that all of his
best friends are Jewish I met Kanye
through a Jewish person right it was
Jewish Jewish best friend reached out
said yeah I would like to meet you and
he's still friends with all these people
so it's for me you have to understand
when I see that tweet the first thing I
think is what are we even talking about
I'm I'm texting with his Jewish friends
there's other so for me to jump in into
the midst of what was said and to say
he's anti-semitic that doesn't register
as something that would make sense right
to me I'm confused I said that this is
confusing to me since he's tweeted that
and by the way the headlines after that
was that he calls for the deaf to all
Jewish people I thought that was quite
hysterical I don't believe that Kanye
West wants all Jewish people to be dead
and that seemed to me like not a
measured response if you will and by the
way I'm consistent on this
certainly I agree with you he didn't but
but people were so angry that I said
that I don't think he wants all Jewish
people to be dead this tweet seems
incoherent to me let's wait and let him
describe it was essentially my statement
we've waited no I know I know he's gone
on the Lex Freedom right right cast and
he's yeah I just I just want to answer
please I just want to provide that
context of like me responding to just
that tweet right so now people are
saying well he said all this now I'm
like okay but when I said I don't know
what this means I literally didn't know
what it meant and he then clarified that
he did not mean to write the word death
he's clarified about four times now he
did mean to write deaf Con 3 and he was
saying that he was going on the
defensive because he felt that he was
being attacked by Jewish people in his
life so he has clarified that tweet
which is what I essentially said give
him the opportunity to clarify this
incoherent tweet and people took this as
like oh my gosh how dare you
um and yeah so I just wanted to clarify
that so now that you've clarified it
would you say that it is an anti-semitic
sentence
I'm not saying no no now that he's
clarified and said he meant death yeah
would you accept that that is a
anti-semitic sentence well I I think
Defcon 3 is a defensive position and he
said that he felt that he was under
attack by Jewish people in his life so
you know if I understand why there are
people that feel
personally attacked because he's looping
in all Jewish people and they don't
really know what's going on in his
personal life and why he said that and I
have to again state that I am colored by
the fact that I know what led to the
moment of him kind of saying this stuff
and I wish that he would be more
explicit in talking about what he's
going through personally because I think
that it would help people not it
wouldn't justify what he says but it
would help people understand where he's
coming from because I think for a lot of
people it felt like a shock attack on
the entire faith of Judaism right it was
just like how you're saying that all
Jewish people are like because you're
saying that all Jewish people are best
Jewish people or that and I do know that
he went on Piers Morgan and he said I
apologize for saying this I realize that
hurt people hurt people and I have felt
hurt but for whatever reason him saying
that doesn't make the same impact you
know him saying sorry does it make the
same impact as him having said
the initial you know the initial tweet
and people are still pretending that he
meant death to all Jews which I don't
think is fair you know we have to decide
whether or not we are a society that
believes in forgiveness and believes in
apologies or for society that just says
here's who you are for life and we want
you canceled and we never want to see
you again
I believe in forgiveness and and if I
didn't realize she'd apologized and I
believe multiple times important to to
forgive but I guess that's not kind
exactly my question because he went on
onto the Lex Friedman podcast and I
didn't see this and he apparented some
more tropes about the Jewish record
labels being somehow behind uh abortions
of blacks in America and uh Jewish
record labels yeah being behind abortion
of blacks in America okay it's it's not
totally coherent but um a fit to that
kind of those tropes those ancient
tropes about Jews uh referring to the
Jewish media
um and uh it was banned on Instagram for
a conversation with Diddy uh about it
saying Jewish people told you to call me
don't think so these These are troops
now I'm not saying I don't know what's
going on inside Kane's heart inside his
mind I'm a huge fan like you are of his
music and he said some brilliant things
as well I happen to think but I don't
have any trouble in saying that those
are artists cosmetic tropes what what
the intention is behind them it is easy
enough to to identify those but you
don't feel so comfortable well I don't I
don't feel so comfortable with people
seeing that he's been condemned by every
single person in the world he's lost
basically everything he has and they're
not satisfied because they need to see
his friends hurt him publicly I'm his
friend and I've asked people to
recognize that I am his friend and to
realize that it's quite sadistic to then
say we know what he is has dropped him
Gap has dropped him his list everybody's
dropped him everybody is condemned him
the entire world every celebrity has
come down on him but we need you Candace
his personal friend to also say bad
things about him on the airwaves I think
that's it's quite cruel now right but
you can you can you can say loving
things about him but I could also say
could you respect that I don't feel
comfortable talking about my friend sure
and I hope I wish that we could live in
a sire people will go that totally makes
sense because it's it's a bizarre thing
to ask people to harm their friends in
public you know whether or not you are
asking me if I agree that Jewish people
are controlling my every action no I
don't agree with that obviously I won't
agree with that sentiment right but
don't you I don't think Kanye would be
offended if you say you disagree with
him on something I I've been here I've
been well first off you're talking about
the Lex Friedman stuff I haven't even
watched a podcast so I can't respond to
something that I haven't seen but um so
I'm listening to you paraphrase what he
said I can watch if you give me an exact
sentence I can tell you whether or not I
agree with that if you're saying Jewish
people cause abortions that doesn't make
any sense to me so yeah I don't agree
that Jewish people cause all of the
abortions you know what I mean that I
mean that it's incoherent to me
um but you know I do ask for people to
just exercise a little bit of Grace and
to recognize that it's a real friendship
and that it's it's not normal to not be
satisfied by the fact that he's already
been basically wiped off of the face of
the planet virtually by every
organization like he's basically until
he's not allowed to exist right now and
there is a part of this that does feel a
bit sadistic to me that it's like that's
not enough we need you his friend to say
that he is this or he is that oh no no
I'm not saying that you should say he is
this or is that I'm only suggesting that
ask me my opinions about Jewish people
I'm happy to open openly talk about I
think I would hope my record speaks for
itself I mean how many times have I
spoken at The JCC I was there for the
Israel opening in you know in in
Jerusalem so it's you know this idea
that
well if you don't say this exactly that
we wanted to then you are also
anti-semitic is completely unfair and
it's it's wrong quite frankly you know
and it's it's
as I said very bizarre that people think
that you get to just paint me with your
personal feelings about yay West we're
two different individuals I'm not
married to him I have a husband you know
it's like why do I have to why do you
need Candace Owens what more do you want
you've got Adidas you got Gap you've got
easy you've got every store every Airway
Banning him why do you need Candace
Owens like personally to say something
horrible about him well I understand
that you would have been getting a lot
of pushback and the the reason I've
asked you is because I saw you on your
podcast taking his defense so but you
didn't take his defense I actually quite
literally said this is not a defense but
this tweet deathcon 3 is incoherent and
yet people were angry that I said that
but and you admit I mean what is
deathcon 3.
well you have to explain to me it's an
American term oh Defcon 3. yeah yeah and
that's what I was saying I was like did
he mean Defcon 3 deathcon 3 is
incoherent right and he said he typo'd
and he meant to write Defcon 3 and
Defcon 3 is a defensive position so if
you say you're going to go Defcon 3 on
someone you're saying someone on a whole
race of people yeah no I know but what
I'm saying is that the I was responding
to the headlines that he calls for the
death of all Jewish people that's why I
say it's really important
so that is still a an aggressive
statement to make about racism yeah it's
it's aggressive 100 but what I'm saying
is that what I how I've been taken out
of context is when I said on my podcast
following that tweet and I still will
say a thousand times Kanye West does not
want all Jewish people to be dead I
stand by what I said on my podcast right
it is not it is it is completely
ridiculous to think that he was calling
for the death of all Jews right I have
been very measured in my responses every
time there's been somebody that is
hyperbolic I remember for a few months
ago or at the end of last year they were
saying Gal Gadot the Israeli actress
wants the death of all Palestinians
that's dramatic okay she's pro-israel I
remember they then flipped that and so
that Bella Hadid wanted every single
Jewish person to be wiped out that seems
dramatic we should be measured in our
responses I believe that I do not
believe irrespective of people that he
is angry at that are in his inner circle
who happen to be Jewish right that
there's not all Jewish people it's you
know painting a broad brush which we
shouldn't be doing ever
um and I think that he should call those
people out by name because I think that
it would provide more clarity as opposed
to making it seem like it's every Jewish
person that you ever deal with and I've
said that I've said that on my podcast
there is probably more clarity that
needs to be provided here and they
shouldn't even mention that they're
Jewish you just call out individuals he
has a problem
but uh Kanye is uh pushing back against
this consolation cancellation and is
bought a I believe buying a state in
parlor social media and um which is the
uncancelable social media or so yay says
is that something to be excited about
exciting in general that he's the first
black person to ever own a social media
company that could be the headline
instead it's Kanye West this can't you
know Kanye West that and he's this he's
that and I think that it's exciting that
the markets are breaking a bit and that
people that there's more than one option
in general that's a kind of a larger way
to answer the question I think it's
great that Elon Musk is taking over
Twitter I think it's great that you know
Donald Trump started his own
organization I think we have all felt
that on Twitter I mean my account got
locked because I said that we need to
talk about transgenderism as a mental
illness is it fair that my lock my
account got locked and yet people can
throw the n-word at me every second I
can't get along for two months the
double standards are insane yeah and so
I think it's great that we're
diversifying and having more platforms
and more options full stop irrespective
of whether it's yay or somebody else so
you've in your book and uh across your
work you've spoken about the problem of
big tech and and media uh propaganda do
you think that the social media industry
or can be disrupted do you think this is
an achievable to create an uncastable
social media that can compete with your
Instagrams your twitters I do yeah and I
think that before perhaps we didn't
realize that we needed to compete in
that regard because we just thought okay
it's a platform and everybody should be
allowed on it which tends to be my
perspective I don't by the way believe
that the answer to hate speech is
censorship I think the answer to hate
speech is Love Speech I think if you if
you believe that somebody is saying
something that is hateful you should
debunk them Point by point on what
they're saying right and like if you
believe that the Jewish people don't
control the media why are you censoring
it give them a platform and say let me
show you why you're wrong right that's
my personal opinion it's like it doesn't
make hate go away to censor it actually
what ends up happening if you don't
believe say that like if so if we sit
here and we say well Kanye West said was
completely crazy and wrong right the
Jewish people don't control the media
yeah you don't prove that by censoring
him you prove that by actually allowing
him to say it sitting across from
somebody and having them debunk it Point
by point right right and saying uh no
actually Fox News is owned by Rupert
Murdoch and he's not a Jewish person
right for some reason we've gotten into
this weird space where people believe
that if you just censor it it goes away
actually what happens is it makes it
bigger right well it makes it bigger so
now you have people that are saying did
they just prove yay's point right and
now these are the things people they
just proved his point and it's like no
guys this is why it's important to
conquer speech that we believe is wrong
with more speech right and so it is my
hope that people start to see that all
across society that censorship is not a
strategy it's it's actually if something
is wrong prove it to be wrong so that we
can as a society move forward yeah um if
that truth doesn't need a sense to
defend it it doesn't and for some reason
people have this category of hate speech
which I could just answer it and it in
my honest opinion it creates more hate
because people get angry and frustrated
do you have a personal line on on what
speech is not acceptable so for example
in this country if you incite violence
it's illegal it's do you are you a free
speech absolutist it's absolutely okay
to say anything or do you have your own
lines on that I
I personally if you gave me a scenario
where I might draw a limit I'd be
interested to find it okay I'm I'm you
know I believe that free speech is 1A
I'm very 1A I would almost say I'm a
free free speech absolutist yeah well
you might come up with some scenario I'd
be like you know what but by the way
speech has consequences you know what I
mean it has consequences it clearly has
had consequences for gay and I have said
you know if Adidas wants to drop on that
as well from the right to their company
yeah so freedom of Association you feel
that's you're totally acceptable
response to Kanye you don't think you
haven't got a problem you're a private
company they if the you could drop
someone I I mean at my company I would
drop someone if they told me that they
believed in trans children and the
surgeries are forming on them I've
dropped my heartbeat that's my line it's
my company yeah it's my company if
somebody said that you know we're going
to use this platform and talk about why
children should be you know I work for
you but I'm going to have my child go
through I would drop them it's for me
it's a it's a morality thing but I'm not
saying that you should be able to get
another job go align yourself with
whoever you know you want to
um align yourself with you know and so
yeah I think that it can come out of
consequence and you know that's within
that Adidas as well within their right
to stop association with whomever they
want for whatever reason
um so the last thing I want to ask you
about is the future of America you are a
conservative activist and a commentator
are you hopeful for the conservatives
for the Republicans Will trump come back
at the next election if he does would
you support him what what do we need to
know
so I'm very positive I do believe that
conservatives are winning and one of the
litmus tests for that is the fact that
they're using fact Checkers now for
everything we say the one of them is at
their demanding censorship always like I
said for me talking about the trans
stuff they just ban it you know I want
to discuss it I believe that censorship
is only necessary when you're losing the
narrative and I think that the left had
a Stranglehold in the narrative but
because people like me have broken
through and other conservatives people
on The Daily wire platform Matt Walsh
talking about the trans kids and stuff
and we've garnered to following they're
realizing wait a second we no longer
have a Stranglehold in the conversation
and they're becoming more desperate and
they're starting to think that they can
just censor it and make it go away going
back to my point of why it doesn't work
um we need good ideas to conquer bad
ideas and so I always say people be
encouraged by that there I I sense a
desperation in the media we have you
know CNN is our far left Network and
they're saying we must you know ban all
conservatives I mean we need to have
more functions left
far left they're not Communists I know
um what do you mean
I I don't a CNN Marxist Communists left
yeah they're definitely marxists without
question I mean like the principles if
you read Karl Marx about being
anti-family and why it was against the
state what they are trying to do in
every regard is to grow up state
right the state will deal with climate
change the state will deal with you if
you need to have pills for the rest of
your life because you're trans the state
will deal with covid you just stay at
home and lock yourself down it's Marxism
you know I mean it's it's belief in the
state as a higher power and they mock
Christians on air they mock Christians
so yeah I believe they're Marxist at CNN
100 I stand by that and that's why I
like to differentiate between the left
and the far left because not necessarily
everybody watching CNN is a Marxist
right and I think that some of them are
just have not yet fallen out of love
with what it used to mean to be on to be
a Democrat you know you grew up in a
time like I said where it was much more
normal and I like when I was growing up
it just wasn't this radical I was a
liberal I was friends with Republicans
um and all of that was perfectly fine
but we're now in an entirely different
circumstance so I do think that CNN has
leaned into full Marxism uh you do you
do think they have gone into full
Marxism okay well I've yet to see
evidence of that but I think it's
possible to you know to have some ideas
that align with Marxism but but anyway
back to Trump
what's do you think he'll run again what
does that mean for America if he does I
do think that he'll run again I hope he
runs again because I think there's a lot
of you know fundraising that's being
done
um maybe not directly with his campaign
but people believe that he's going to
run again I think it would be sort of
like why didn't you run you know instead
of just teasing it for years and I think
that we'll have to see you know I have
always said I'm committed to truth
whatever that truth is obviously I was
very vocal in my support for Trump but
I'm not just oh my gosh worship Trump
I'm gonna vote for him automatically if
he runs who are the candidates running
against him yeah are there any
politicians you are excited about
there's I mean like new politicians that
have kind of I I really like Christy
gnome in North Dakota I love somebody
who's not known at all uh but he's a
congressman Thomas Massey if he ran for
president like goodbye I'm like I'd vote
for him a million times he's just a
congressman from Kentucky that has every
single value and belief that
um and he stands by his principles and
uh obviously DeSantis is I think he has
really risen to the challenge he wasn't
as good on his feet when he was running
for governor but I think what he did in
covid during covet was heroic I think he
he put an end to covid because of his
State saying no more and then it kind of
pressured all the other states to do
something about that
um and he's he's measured you know he's
quite measured and I think his team the
team around him is great so there's a
lot of people that I'm very excited
about and when I know everyone who's
running I'll be able to make a more
measured you know conclusion about who
I'm gonna vote for well I look forward
at that time to speaking with you and uh
are you optimistic or pessimistic about
the future of America I'm optimistic I
think you know we are having a Clash of
the Titans in many ways but I think
we're winning so there's nothing not to
be optimistic about if I wasn't
optimistic I wouldn't get out of bed I'd
be depressed
kind of zones thank you so much for your
time it's been a pleasure speaking with
you thank you thanks for having me
[Music]